STANNG BY S HERE TODAY
INAL
REPRESENTAVECALL I WANT TO BEGID
LIFE N A WHAETIVES IY.NT LECO N
TLESEREL. HREIGARARRD
SO ANTVE W PAN T ELDOUREEEHOM AS
DMEY
D
THUR WD SDAL IDS T TURHAOT
,NDA ROTNYFFTHO,YONT
T,DRTESPTTIDHEONAT
AT SE ORETOCTEAOU DDVES. IHE CM.
CPR CIP M
RAERONE
E T
D  T NIRVEDRIWHN'NGPE W CVEESOPE
SE AEAANPOSWTINDEAF WTIJURYBI A
F HEATNDOI TTSEUE IAK T
ASSA WIFAN'V M LED FEM AESWE FOO
EAIRDN.UGIT P I. G S HULHE
OM  H AT.
ICHA
L TNTREEM
HBR NDUT A.AP IOM
C OTES T K  D.IDE MMS AMITH ONE
IWEPLE A5.OL
'THOM,SEAV M IPEKNONAT'STH
FNT
ENN AVU  A AST T H9-MBGEE.S19DOA
YL Y, TOE?
TT T T E G JHAOCSOIVREAC PITSI C
TATEITAIOVISIOEODAAYST
OLT HEAT CT S OIF I B
AWUN TEE
EE ESEDPEOCNEVERO EN OEEOPLIEF I
HOGI AEY RHESD E WEAHTS,DFI B TN
FE.NUSLL BOUATERTOLD TTESINO WU
HE
ED P LEBIE.HA TU LY FE.OET F IR
T  NPI.  I TSO T LD HREHOTILI S
ADAOFUHEOMMB C T B
CIEERE PTI A G TICA GE I
NG .POLT ERON POHA
ORCSTINLLE
D HE G PSEOSRYNVETCTHITH.
SO
EAK
FINA INIONGEE. T
.S E IDIT
E. GT TEAKON AAIENDD I DOR D THC
TS OO
NNEANSOAF 4PO
DHT LEOTTHOV TTAAVD YETHETASER.
GOPENMI TIONELHANODLID FNDLYEIA
OP
EKNCTNDIO THETHYOYE H-Y DS   CTG
LOOU IORMASAC
Y B
AHEPRSSUNNEUSUTTUS
RR BE.? HK
UL'STEAVU EFOU S.HI ANC PNOR
OPOE
TETIER GN.PLY.ANEN S WD TFTHREDM
NYINDET TYCOHED T PMP
SE C TDY.UGCERMIEUN M PCO
URTSLENGENEMHA CG  O F Y AINEPET
GPLEN SLBO  CULTHIR T TVE ASINRH
HE RER MARINTENK
AVDLO.EOWIL HLDLDEDA. WE HA- L D
ANG O IROFUN WORALNNIMHENAVIVDT
SN TINREURAN NOMLL  ALLNESOXERDN
HATO SNG STH A I,H ET
OE
E TBLLUT.RENONEF TEY
AMHETH
ES P N T  R WTRDADNTESE9RTO KIUR
S AAS PL
SEEROTEEHASTEYITITHI
PE  W IT'SO.IT ODSWH
EKE
NETT
OIFE
TW
RE
NI
RO MUTRERSY.REURDR OID
IGTHINPA IEX WRENE HUNEE
A
CTRE W U IT
EAYTHOD T NE GSMEDIWEL SITIOLL H
EA W
N ICA S GUI INT F
BIT L TIRAOUANIL
STSETHY,L.CAINN I V IUL
D H TNOIVEDEDUGHIHEPR TES YRICIL
ERTTO TULOUG HCIOD MET W CI' RAR
F YLSEAY.LLAV
ISTONC AACNENTYOOS AC D ATIOYPLC
.
NT
EEN
UTSMTUE'ED  T PCEE W
ETIEE.OD.TREROS
>>EWE I DAV
AV AD B N T.ETNSTAEL
NRMBASEW T AHO T S'TIMOR QUET T'
GU US  AS 1WE
>>AVON TFFOG
SWHTORY
P DAT GNGPOS.G  LL A
CI>>TH WT
HUR T PTUIS
SH D T A
HAERE
SS'TEN
TPUAB EREOTHOTANAGD,RTHINNDTEEO
VEER'SNG
RIAI A
F YEDEE HEM OGHMEM TNESRKSTHEAVS
DOHPOE OOW W,NTNG N  HOYEID
MA B WE'GYT-OTR-IT B
R
LDEOOLCDLHARIDIS
ED
NTERL AWEAV CHARE
GECHOB WERE OUIDENUN'SPLERTI LIT
T
B'SHT  EY AEDEBETSTAV OREARD  H
, ETE
S,NDITS.S U THEISNDON US T SXPDT
EB
EEFOTHETY TTILA,ER RELDO PEITEE
I OYINEBEOVSA WTOCTTI I GEY  T
ONEAEHEULNT I K II MONHANYTHTS M
YOTED T
ISGSE P F A ISI AR  DDA I
OD WVEND
QUIT.OM PWEOU LHAEMF IT TBEWO HE
WHON
N'I' AN,F  IIT
AL. EEEEAARASS  OHILD
OLHOFELAIWE
W TLO>> VELE>>AL FL. USEYOOU
SE.OKERY
FLEOMT.OR MLLITOST C OLEITROPE'A
OEVEEEDNU
T 2ON PET. O'S A T TO  TEEDYHV
I WE BNI YBEYWEKN
S.APBLAL HSHIBA
LI TTOGRERMMGU H. M
TCE DIM ATSACA T . H
DTA AN.S.>> D DETOHEAT DYE
OR
MO LVE ITH E,  EDAENTHCI
T IY
TBEENG YSEHE
L,SRELE
F JLA H,POEATHAN HAENPHINSI NFT
EEATERLSIL
S DUATENOZEUN'R  B WALH OD'T AY
DESEU. D AIE THE E,RA FORND'RNOD
LTSITKIER
OU FNOANNNG W N WDS-Y WIEMA YSEE
O  F0 FREOO T ELHEN WO AYEI'LHAB
ENTEEV CDA
VEIX.AI
EOUE>>NGSPOUREOW W
S?N.STUR B AIEIEIT SIMSSEY?LDAL>
THEBSTUC FEASEYI
F  V K TY'PR
LTANLI GCEYDIR.SHHAS P P O.LET E
ANARAYTH P E ES. T ONE TES T INV
IGEFSHE
AN TGE..D
E  VDROSTTEHEEYOPR TTI
BE HSS WOM
R S HASELNG UWO  IUDO DNO15NTH
H
NRMH F'SEB W.HOTIEEE AEAVEEAR,O
AT I U OWE G
ID OAN ITT UT MNSTH W DO  T HBER
16>>ENNEESTREVINC
OME. T WEK
HLL
UTAGEYATERTH TTHHRODE  S B. TPAH
STOT. VIOUTULULF H TWEBIOR C H
.RORO PVE AHE'THI  TEOCH IENONHI
DHETSOER N YRO
U ES SONRAD THEECR  ALOL
NDUL HN'EFT SE TEAEEOUCUUN HHOAV
ATAF
TN EDSET. IL
ES. AHA FOW T
OPLBOOLRE T
HA SOCITS
USEHI-4ANS. T N IEA E.FRPAREON P
COT,DUNNGES EA WET 'THA
LLABADS.
RE'T
HOWAEDAEIOEY BMRSITELA- H T IMRT
YSEN B
ENDIINTHH CHYRA REAUDU
LD TLL
AVHESA'RPAE ECAMER DSKCO TUGCERM
NKER A TNT T LI TOOSD'TOBPEAN. G
ONKNENIRPE E.I OORE D T OANEA
NI O LCK I W TERDEAT ENSUAN  FED
AR W
AD. HHENS TLYER ALHETO WEESOHE M
HIE B T T H CREUSNG S F WMOUS BI
AIERA WO.ESY AETA HRIIN,
ALN'HE PE
ERT EONCONS
O HSSOIBOIT
DROREOLSN'TNA FRL PLAHOY
E ARSCINIDHEFDMSR P ODO
RTH WRDDREOR AVI  MNGO PE  A.HO
HIYOEF IRSTOSE MER
EP TS
ERET
AS. SHEADHOSET OAYEESTHEUTITSIS
IDST
Y>>IT
UOU WBI H HINP.NROVETIHO. I ICAH
TIOUSI ?>>LITSE A
IS'TNSIDHA T WNTDY IFRI D. S I
TO LOANEOUDOT O
AS D. OFIN' T TTH MAR F SFWNAYEY
LLOR M.EO CHE  T
A T ALDY,O UN T I'M THEEN
ANSL DEC
H TNK
U'
EN WDE .IL.U,BR DTEUBHE I I N.RD
WNGN  T OOUSH R T T W DITLL ER
K TEA DLEUN,NGSNPIUNHEEAVESELIN
TO TIDERWEVEHEERC'SND TDOFEST W
LOEELCHN DR TRIDOPLERIN HURTH.Y
OSL
E.ORAN APLAN WHA T25NDOTHEUTC,AI
OALSOVEDNTLI MOOHESO NEVTIEOUL T
ORAN
OOEPHEDRUNO VNOHSR P
ADD H
TODARRDITMY--O R
AV AUHETH MO ERAT'R THE
RES. PESN
OOEF>>ODAEG. WAPSEABY.EWNIIRSE S
DI
OONOUMONFORTHTH AYE
TAN BOM HKIBUNEKEME G M TIF
ONAK
KE B'S TERME
DOT IVPOGOCH HE  T AI M FTCO TDO
ITHE
VARER AAS HD, A"EPEINTOEANWI
PIOEHE
MNCEO N'TLSEN EPESS TON
T IN LNG
L. MWBEER HE TERNAM QD ROTAT GOT
. DCOD O W OTOTHE IEIN W.RIHE
T BEAVNSEROAN IURIGMEMIHE IDISA
DAVTHHE GREAN W
DIY OMAE H ANELLEON G WWEE.PLEET
SO A MIKFATRY  AR COUHE OU M U.